this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everybody it's April 20th it's a
beautiful day I'm in front of plant
science and just to my left there's a
beautiful Magnolia that is perfectly in
full bloom right now I'd like to go to
show it to you well here is the Magnolia
which is a cross with Koba stellata
it's called Leonard Messel it's a
cultivar and it's just beautifully in
bloom right now white and pink let's go
in to see the beautiful branching
structure if I can get close to a flower
we'll see their beautiful petals on this
see the many pedals this beautiful
Leonard metal magnolias many petals
refers to the stellata
parentage of this
this was discovered the chance seedling
in England and it's become very very
popular it's actually fragrant which is
unusual for magnolias and quite
beautifully early so this is the Leonard
vessel Magnolia which has cova tallada
as one of its parents giving it that
multi peddled appearance
well here we are in the ILR courtyard
and I wanted to show you the Yoshino
cherry this is prunus yellow iNSYS it's
the same cherry that's in the title
basin of Washington DC the famous cherry
blossoms there so we have this right
here and it's in full bloom let's go
look at it
closer
almost white pinkish white
beautiful cherry but really full of
blooms after the blooms of course the
leaves will come on but this is a really
extraordinary bleep beautiful Yoshino
cherry blooming a little bit early
because it's in the ILR courtyard so
it's uh just a little warmer in here and
they bloom just a little bit earlier
quite a few here
my line below that you'll see the
forsythia also in full bloom right now
so beautiful
prunus you know winces Yoshino cherry
wonderful to see it it's pretty short
live too in terms of the blooms but if
you get here for a week or two it's
really worth seeing
here is the very lovely prunus sarge nti
accolade when the earliest cherries to
flower it's really gonna boot aful pink
flower it's always a smile harvard era
of the cherries that your or the other
cherries come out later but this one is
an early one and let's go look at the
flower specifically
if you really see the double nature we
say double means many petals on the
flower doing a great soft look mrs.
wanted a popular of the early cherries
called accolade Funes accolade which is
a charge MDI parent may be a beautiful
plant at this time of year
hi everyone I am walking along the taro
road bioswale and on my right there is
the special sorb area sorbets folia sim
which I'm gonna show you just a minute
so here's this bushy some shrub and what
makes it different than the straight
species is this yellow foliage that
comes out very early in the spring if I
come in closer
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu